last year at the World Economic Forum
there were a number of people talking
about the fact that they see big data
it's like a new asset class
I think Zack bug who is Marissa Meyers
husband was telling us about this also
when we were doing research he and rest
were both incredibly helpful to us and
kind of conceptualized in the whole
project there's a story in the book
about a gentleman who has a pacemaker
it's a wireless pacemaker so throughout
his day the data from his heart is
transmitted to his doctor and he
actually spent time looking at his
exercise his nutrition his alcohol
consumption and he wanted to find out
whether there's some correlation between
his other activities and when his
pacemaker kicked in so he called the
manufacturer saying could I get copy the
last six months of my heart data and
they said sorry I said this is
proprietary and he said wait a second
this is my heart you've been collecting
information about my heart I want a copy
of the information and they ever refused
to give it to him what I love about the
story is it kind of makes you think well
wait a second how it why is it that my
browser history is being sold to the
highest advertiser just credit card
companies selling the data about what
I'm consuming everybody's trading in all
the data that I'm creating here's a guy
who's someone's actually you know
recording his heartbeat and when his
pacemaker kicks in and yet we don't have
access to most of this we have no
control over who's using it it's very
valuable and yet we as the people
manufacturing it don't seem to have any
say over who's using you know what
they're doing with it and I think that's
got to change I think that we have to
have the ability to decide what we share
and what we don't I read recently that
there was a credit card company that
admitted that they were actually looking
at people's facebook profiles and that
people that were listening to rap music
were given a lower credit rating score
because somehow statistically people
listen to rap music words somehow or
more of a credit risk my 12 year old
listens to rap music the fact the fact
that there are algorithms and programs
out there that are making decisions
about my ability to get credit then I
have no idea what I'm being judged by
what books I read who I talk to what
music I'm listening to this is very
scary stuff the whole point of doing
this human face of big data project
which was sponsored by the way by EMC
one of the largest players in the big
day
space but they you know I'm a journalist
so they had no right of review or
censorship they didn't even see this
project to the book and the iPad app
came out they basically gave us the
ability to kind of start this global
conversation a lot of my friends in the
journalism world who are hearing about
during big data for the first time have
said to me well is this just a big you
know promotion for big data is it just a
big data is gonna solve all of our
problems and my response has been that
every time there's a new tool whether
it's the internet or cell phones or
anything else you know all these things
can be used for good or evil I mean
there's no technology is neutral it
depends on how it's used so I think that
what I'm trying to do what I'm hoping
that the human face of big data project
will do is get people talking and
thinking about this in a way that
perhaps is is thought-provoking and
disturbing and exciting and there's a
lot of stories in the book where you go
that's so cool that's wonderful I love
this a lot of people believe that the
ability to measure and instead of doing
a random sampling which is what we used
to do we used to like go out and and ask
people twenty thousand people a question
and then we say this is what everybody
thinks we're able to do much more
nuanced now we're almost able to pull
people all over the world at the same
time there's five million people now
that carry cell phones even its but
particularly in the developing world so
we're actually it's a lot of people in
speculating that soon we may be able to
actually measure the heartbeat of
everybody on earth simultaneously which
is kind of a fascinating idea what would
that mean if you could actually listen
to this global heartbeat and actually
sense this pattern of behavior across
the planet in the course of the day I
mean in a way Twitter has become that
Twitter's become sort of a new a new way
of sort of listening in on the
conversation in real time so there's a
lot of questions out there big data as a
brand new tool we'd never seen anything
quite like this before
and and I hope people will turn the
pages of the book and want to share the
stories with each other
you